Hi, I'm [inaudible] from Texas. I Google,
I'm very happy to welcome Kate Mckinnon
and Mila Kunis for the spy who dumped me?
No.
Oh,
welcome to Google.
Thank you. Oh, how are you
reaching the floor? If I sit back,
are we all going to sit like
that? Okay. There we go. Wow.
Yeah.
Wow. You all left your desk. I'm
sorry. You're right. You're right. Oh,
you're a lady.
Okay. Okay. Oh, okay.
Oh Wow. My voice travels. It's fine.
Thank you. Okay, so thanks for
being here. I can't see Kate.
Mila. Well, other ways I look like this
cause I'm sure I know it. It's okay.
Okay,
so we got to see the trailer,
but can you tell us a little
bit about the movie just so they
okay. I can. Okay. Um,
it's two regular gal,
best friends who become embroiled in an
international espionage adventure for
which they're not prepared.
It's a good one liner.
Great.
Yeah, that's it. Yeah,
that's it.
Chaos ensues. High. Jinks
ensues. Hilarity and shoes. Um,
shoes and shoes issues.
Yeah,
that's true. I did. I saw it
yesterday. They're not lying. Um, okay.
So the movie does a pretty good job of
showcasing female characters that are
allowed to be human, which is awesome
because you don't want, right.
Isn't that great? Because he don't
get to see that a lot in comedy.
So it's really nice. Yes. Yes,
you're correct. Yes. Yes.
Thank you. Um, so, uh,
this is especially nice to see in comedy.
Is that what drew you guys to the part?
Um, is that kind of what you were thinking
about throughout the filming of this
movie?
Yes. I mean, I, yeah, no
it did. I um, I wasn't,
I do one film a year cause I have kids
and family and so it limits the amount of
work that I can do out of town.
I was working on a different film.
This project came along.
I was like,
I can't do it cause it would take me
out for six months and would uproot my
whole family. They're like,
yes, but Kate Mckinnon's in it.
And I was like l so I,
I read the script and then, um, yeah.
Uh,
and what honestly drew me to it was the
relationship between two best friends
being incredibly grounded, incredibly
genuine. Kate talks about this a lot,
but in so many spy movies,
the two characters have a fight.
And that's a catalyst for like,
they have a fight and you're like,
but will they ever get back together
and solve the world's problems? Right?
So we don't have that. Like women or
people in real life don't always fight.
And so, you know, having that resolved
doesn't always resolve other issues.
So I really was drawn to the fact that
our characters were simply friends on a
crazy journey together.
Yeah.
So I uprooted the whole family for six
months for that. So clearly, I too,
I'm kind, I am so flattered
that you did sweetie pie,
because that's time with you.
Thank you.
No, no, no. You guys. No. Like, you know,
in a romantic comedy, in
the best ones, right? You,
you love to watch their
sparkling banter and rapport.
It's fun to watch two people on screen
who liked to talk to each other,
who get each other,
whoever rhythm what we have out of rhythm.
Yes. And so to watch a
friendship that has that,
and it's genuine and I
daresay in real life as well.
Okay.
It's just a joy to watch people
who take delight in each other.
And that's what really drew me to this.
And it felt so real and like my
relationship with my best friend.
And what would happen if we really got
sucked into an international espionage
adventure for which we were not
prepared. Yes, correct. Yeah,
but so that's what I loved about the movie
the most, is seeing a real friendship,
especially between two women where they
raise each other up and they're not,
you know,
the stereotypical like bad eighties
movie where they're like being mean.
Girls like that was really great to see.
So you guys actually didn't know
each other before the film, right?
But became friends during it.
So can you describe each
other in three words?
SMART,
funny,
inspirational it up.
Be Nice.
Can I use the same ones? I'm sorry.
Those are the ones I would use for you.
And May I add
sparkling five basis
entrepreneurial spirit.
Yes. Nice. Okay.
Honestly, your entrepreneurial spirit in
addition to your creative genius is very
inspiring.
Wow.
Lots of love going on here. That's
great. Okay, so in the movie,
the characters try to pick out
the worst song out of a Jukebox,
which I loved as a music fan.
So what would you pick?
I know so many.
Yeah,
I like Pat's songs and I saw
that pop music. I don't know.
I do. I guys, I'm not that hip.
Like it's like I go see indie
bands and silver like and know,
but there's a bad song.
There's a bad song that you like though.
Like I like it's all there.
All the bad songs, no bad,
but none of them stand the test of time.
It's not like you go first and I'll
think of a bad song. I don't know,
like Chumba Walmart or something
who let the dogs out. What
is it?
Timeless.
But it is not a good sign and
prescriptive for, for living.
You get knocked down and you have to
get up again. You have to, what is,
what other choice do you have?
He drinks a whiskey drink.
He drinks of vodka training.
That's Trumbo amber, right? Yes,
you're right. It's very philosophical.
Thank you for bringing that.
Now he sings the songs that remind
them of the good times and the songs.
There might've been the bad times. I
know of the best. Oh, the lyric. See,
it's about positivity.
Okay.
Can you think of a bathroom?
I know one.
I know one song that I think
is a bad sign. I don't know
the name of it. How's it?
Yeah. I don't want to knock the
yard right here. Oh, that's not the,
are they usually don't write it anyway,
so you're fine.
Okay. No, no, no.
Okay. But I've only ever heard one song
that I was like, Oh wow, this is a bad,
I like to Shizam that on the radio.
In your car. Yeah. Yeah. Anyways, so
the Great Jillian Anderson is in this
movie and it appears that Kate and I have
a mutual crush on her because
she's awesome. So a Kate,
at one point you dressed up a
scholar from the x files, which is,
yeah. Awesome. And
you also made a video asking
Jillian to call you. Um, it's,
it's, it's viral. I'm
not making this up. Um,
yes I did. Thanks to the magic
of the Internet. Never disappear.
Maybe we can get Google
to erase it. Uh, so
anybody, anyone, anyone raise
their man help me out. No.
Okay. So what's the weirdest
thing a fan has done for you guys?
There's lots of worst stuff.
Have Kate on the Internet than that guys.
You can just,
you know,
there's some good performances that you
wouldn't let me see that are online.
Right, right. You know, again,
anyone in this room who would
like to choose to just, you know,
hack the code or whatever, I
can do a little cleanup. Um,
you know, talk to me. I'm
sure I'll be forever grateful.
What was the question?
What's the apparently are here to
delete stuff from the Internet?
I have somebody leading something
for Kate. Listen, I'm on train.
I have lots of requests. What a weird
things we've done for what it was. No,
it wasn't.
That was kind of a cool,
I think it was cool,
weird thing you did as a
fan of Jelly. Sure, sure.
So what has been a weird thing
a fan has done for you guys?
Lived in my house. I'm pretty
weird. No Way. Yeah. For Real.
That's it. Pretty good. What do you
mean? Can't just give us a little blurb.
Well,
I going to come to tell the story then
when came in uninvited while I was out of
town.
Wow.
And decided to reside well in May used
to be home because this person was a fan
of yours. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
It's, I'd say it's pretty weird.
Wasn't just a random squatters, not
like my cousin. No, it wasn't. No. Okay.
Okay. Yeah. Wow. Yeah.
Yeah. It's really good. It's
dark and you go, okay. Okay.
Okay, good. That's fine.
Um, for me, you know, Gosh,
no people just do nice things.
I got a lot of,
um,
self generated art about my cat,
Nino because people seem to,
maybe they've heard somewhere
that I have a close,
I'm very close relationship with
my cat and I know your cat. Well,
you call it unhealthy. I call it
a marriage. I don't know what.
Anyway, I've gotten a lot of
art about Nino and that. I
appreciate it. I love you.
They paint, they paint, they
knit, they make tee shirts.
Do they know what your cat looks
like? Oh yeah. Oh really? Google it.
Thank you. I believe we're like in the
headquarters. We're not, you're not,
that's in San Francisco.
But this is close to your clubs.
Like an outpost for that
next question.
Oh, you guys are killing me
already. Okay. And a good way.
So both your characters have
hidden skills in the movie, a,
everything from trapeze to video
games, shooting. Are you these things?
Do you do it all and you're in your lives?
And more importantly,
do you have any hidden skills?
Um, I, I have no hidden skills.
I have.
Okay.
I can make fettuccine.
Is that a hidden skill?
I roll my own pasta. Okay. When I
have time. Yeah. Yeah, that works.
What else?
I played the cello.
Oh, me too. Yeah. Rotting in jail.
Can your cat cow?
Sure. Oh no, he hates
stringed instruments. Oh Gosh.
When I pick up that chiller that he runs
to the other room that's not play the
guitar I do. I still, you
musically inclined would be a good,
what's not very hidden.
I feel like people kind of know
you're musically inclined. Yeah.
Can you do like a back who,
yeah, that's a good hidden,
I'm not going to do right now, but no, I
can't do, I can't do a backbend. Can you
make very vulnerable position?
Yeah, I'm going to say no,
just some APP, but on the spot. I'm
doing it back then. Great. Okay.
So I got a couple more questions for you
guys then. What's happening? Nothing.
I'm just, I'm ready. I'm ready. I see
you're ready. Yes, I see. Yeah. Okay.
So if you weren't acting, what
would you be doing? Carpentry.
10000% carpentry.
Okay.
Specifically perhaps cabinet making,
but maybe just um,
general carpentry or
refinishing furniture.
Also quite interested in
plumbing and electric.
Cool.
She's on Hgtv all day.
I love,
I mean to see the fruits,
the physical fruits,
the wooden fruits of one's labor after
the day I feel would be very satisfying.
And having refinished a
few pieces of furniture.
Okay.
Feel like I,
um,
I got the ball rolling so that's my
alternate life that I may turn to at some
point. We'll see. What have you
made? I just refinished, you know,
some cedar chests
and you
okay. You speak as though I have
not, I have no idea. I was like this,
I am aware of this. What, what, what would
I be doing if not this? Yes. Cooking.
Oh, so you're a good cook. Yeah. Nice.
Yeah. What do you like to make everything.
I'm a pretty good cook. Bake everything.
No. Horrible Baker. Oh No, no,
no, no. Like I burned
toast. I don't bake, Cook.
Like I cook really well all
the time. I mean, I can bake,
but just not desserts I guess I
should say. Not like a cookie Baker.
I have to say I'm the same. Yeah. You
and I love to cook a lot. I love to cook.
I can't bake a cookie.
Like I literally didn't know that
you could buy those premiums. Look,
he's in there like this is, I can't do
it either. I will burn it. Same. Yeah,
I know why Mila. It's because you
don't play by the rules. I don't,
I also don't like recipes.
Maybe neither follow direction.
Who does that make it up?
Feel it? It's like ideas.
It's like recommendations. Yeah. Eh?
Yeah. No. Yeah. No, I'm with it. Okay,
so if you were stuck on a desert island.
Yup. It's one of those questions,
but somehow could access only one
John of movies. What would you pick?
Romantic comedies.
Horror.
I hate her. I hate it. You don't watch
any movies? Scary movies. I'm no,
like I genuinely get scared and then I
can't sleep. And then my husband's like,
this is the biggest mistake ever.
Why did I let you watch it?
I'm like a 12 year old. Like I was
the last one you watched. I haven't.
It's the shining. I don't know. I
don't like, I really do get scared.
Like I get very emotional and then I
worry if there's a child in it. I'm like,
well, where's its mother? Like I get very
uncomfortable very quickly. I like, well,
the child usually eats its mother,
so if there's a child in the preview,
I promise you I'm not seeing that movie.
Like I am not kidding you.
If they have like a child and the door
opens and it's like, Huh? I'm like, nope,
not happening. You love that.
I find it very relaxing.
What's your favorite scary movie?
Horror movie?
Yeah,
the one that really laid me out on my
parent's floor for a week and a half was
the original omen with
Gregory Peck. Ooh, very good.
When he goes into that grave,
spoiler alert and finds the dead Jackal.
Ooh,
wow. That's what you want is watch
by yourself on a desert island.
Well,
you and I should not be deserted together,
but did you hear her original answer
was water and that's because she has an
entrepreneurial spirit.
She knows what she needs to survive and
she also knows that she can sell it to
the other people.
Right?
Yeah.
For better movies. Yeah. All right, so,
so who or what inspired you
to get into acting and comedy?
Oh, I don't know. I was nine. Kate,
you're, I don't know. Maybe Lucille Ball.
Actually I think you, you
know what, maybe Lucille Ball,
cause the first thing I saw when
I came to the states was, um,
was nick at night and I said watching
a lot of that. So it was a lot of,
I love Lucy Three's company.
I'm talking about like Mary Tyler Moore,
like a lot of old, like 60, 70 shows.
Right. And predating that. And so I think,
um, I would definitely say, uh, probably
inspired by Lucille Ball. Well, cool.
Yeah. Um, uh, for, for me it
was just Saturday night live.
Really just that and Mel Brooks movies,
my house, it was all Melbourne cause
all the time he had no choice. Yeah.
Favorite Mel Brooks movies for both of you
producers,
young Frankenstein, young Frankenstein.
Good choice. It's their choice.
Yeah. Yeah. Which one?
Yeah.
Okay. So, um, last question.
I think we have time from, uh,
one question and then we'll open
up the floor to audience questions.
And I'll throw this and be super
awkward about this. What's that?
It's our a microphone that we
throw to the audience to ask.
Neat. Yeah. Yeah.
They come up with a throw a
ball microphones. So cool.
So, um, so what is,
what would be your dream
role as an actress?
Yeah,
surely there are so many,
there are so many
badass women of history
that I would love to inhabit
persona wise and also wig wise.
Um,
I will say that my dream role in musical
theater is Miss Hannigan for a new view
who pries musical theater.
But yeah,
I know.
I don't know.
I have nothing. Okay. I can make something
up, but I don't, you know, I don't know.
I was the first thing that pops into your
head like a rock star or someone? No,
no.
A vox style.
You wouldn't want to play a rockstar like
who anyone like wants to fit everyone.
I mean like [inaudible] anyone,
anyone from Janis Joplin to,
no, I should do,
if you're portraying a rock star,
you should have like at least rhythm.
Can you not sing at all? Well,
I mean, I like to think I can.
Okay. Don't answer that
one. I'll answer for us. No,
I know you love me.
And they know
you're a very supportive friend.
You're very nice.
Why don't you sing no,
and let us [inaudible] guys,
here's the thing.
Don't worry guys.
I do a cartoon called family
guy and for I have Google,
wrong audience, wrong audience there
too nerdy. There's, they're like, well,
we don't solve algorithms.
It's like that widow. But um,
for 15 years I've been like,
I'm not seeing it on your show.
Mcfarlane made me sing 15 years ago,
three lines and it took three hours
and I was like, I'm not doing this for
three months ago.
They put me in a recording booth and I
had to sing a whole thing of Oklahoma.
So in a year you will hear meg and this
is by the way, when, if ever you see this,
should you ever want to remember?
That's me trying.
That's me trying to be good.
That's all you need to know.
I don't need to showcase it. Everybody
will see it. It's a family guy.
It's coming soon. Let me singing
Oklahoma the best I can. Keep in mind.
Well, I look out for that guy. I
mean guys, it's brilliant. Yeah.
Okay, so who wants to ask
the first question? Nobody.
I'm going to, I'm going to throw this at
you, so I don't hate anyone in the head.
Can you hear me okay? Yes, I
have the question. Familiar.
I've heard tofor and Ashton,
a few people talk about how great
the 70 show it was making that,
would you make a movie followup to
that or get back into it in any way?
Yeah, I mean, yeah, it was great. Um,
I feel like I'm too old to
reprise a 16, but, um, would we,
I, yeah, of course. I think
we love it. Plus I met my
husband on the show, so yeah,
I think the show's great.
Yeah.
Another question from me. Do you still
play games to find time for kids?
Sorry, I know I spent, what is it feed?
So it's a 20 to 24,
25.
It took up a lot of my life and
I would shoot movies and um,
and you go on break, so you get, it's like
a five minute break in between scenes.
And I was like, I gotta go. And it'd
be like on some rate and they're like,
well you need to go back to set. And I
was like shy, like I think it literally,
it was just too much. It was unhealthy.
It was just not healthy for me.
Have a question.
Raid
What game weights? You know
what I'm talking about Ray Ray?
Um, like if you do first person
shooter games or any like,
like any of those games you
can kind of pop in and out.
But if you're doing a
group game where it's,
if you're not going through the
story mode, you see what you started,
then you are,
then you are responsible for your group.
And I lot of times it was either
like a healer or whatever.
Long story short that. Okay.
What's the next question?
You do have secret skills.
Wow.
So I have a question about your hidden
talents that you were talking about.
You were saying that you
might take up woodworking.
Have you ever happened
to talk to Ron Swanson?
I did an episode of something and
Nick Offerman was there and yeah,
we talked about furniture making the
whole time. Wouldn't incredible life.
He has married to the eminent
Megan Mullally sitcoms,
star Comedians Xtrordinair and it
makes gorgeous pieces with live.
Would edges come on?
He does like he does like big tape.
Huge beautiful pieces. Yes.
Yeah.
He knows what's good.
What's up?
Oh, I have two questions.
Simple and difficult. One,
the difficult one.
Do you use any Google products?
Yeah.
The simple one is, since you mentioned
you have some entrepreneurial spirit,
can you suggest any Google products
you brought up that Google should
develop or something like that? Yes. Um,
but he didn't answer. I can answer
this. I do have, um, some, uh,
friends working on,
um,
Kitty Hawk and so the
flying car from Google,
so I can recommend that if you'd like
to buy it, you can contact Dave Clark.
He's selling them. I'm Sebastian is
the one who's working on the product.
It's a fantastic product. I Have Nikki
has held on to Vegas to, uh, fly it.
But uh, yeah, I a Hla answer,
I just thought of Shuba yeah,
their stuff.
Okay.
She speaks Russian. I, um,
I have an idea. I was just looking
at these plants and I was like,
what about Google irrigation?
If one of your plans for you,
it's a self watering,
um, self timing water.
I'll take 10% thanks.
Any others? Oh, here, I'll
go in the middle here. Versus
similar to the question about
what would be your dream role.
Do you have a dream actor that you want
to work with that you haven't worked
with yet?
And this is for both of you.
Okay.
I Love Matt Damon. So, yeah.
My husband knows.
Okay.
I Love Matt Damon guys. I do, you know,
one of my,
one of my comedy heroes of all time is
Catherine O'hara and I've never met her.
So with, yes. So next to her was shot.
What did she say?
Nothing,
but I got really excited and it was
on Melrose? In Las? Yeah. Annika.
And I was making a left hand
turn and she was in an SUV.
I'm next to me and I literally,
I think I went like this. Okay.
I think I just didn't do anything other
than looking at her. I love her. I,
that's my story. That's all I
got. That's a minute of your life.
You'll never get back. What?
You guys were in the same car?
No.
I saw her at a yogurt land and I freaked
out the one on Sawtelle and Olympic.
So maybe she hangs out there.
What flavor would be
having a toppings of joy?
I don't know. I don't know. Yeah. Okay.
Hello. Okay. So, um, during filming,
did you have any funny moments
that you had between each other?
You spend a lot of time on set, any pranks
or anything fun thing all day? Pranks?
No,
cause we're adults
cause I'm in between
takes that was nursing.
So I would honestly to answer
seriously, it was with my baby. But um,
Paul book the genome
and then Kate,
we just Chitchat with me and then I would
go into my little hole and pump in her,
feed the baby.
Like it was so not that exciting.
I saw lots of bathrooms in,
Oh,
everywhere we were everywhere I pumped it
was a bathroom and like a little sheet,
you know. What'd you do? Banana
peels all day. Every day.
Yeah. I killed a few people. No,
I'm kidding. No, I don't like,
I don't like practical jokes. I don't
either. That's not true. If, oh,
you like pranks I not done to me.
Right,
right. No, I liked, I like done
to other people. I'm a hub,
a hub on the whole country,
so I don't feel that I would ever do a
prank just in case something horrible
went wrong. Like if you drop a
bucket of water on someone's head,
what's to say that they're not
looking up and they drown in the water
then he got a lawsuit now Paul Book.
Gl.
Sorry. Oh, sorry.
So we got one more question.
Make it a good one.
Shoot. Too much pressure. Oh my goodness.
Okay. Scenes on social media, it's
like going on like super fast.
Like nowadays, like in
everything, it's there. Um,
since you're a celebrity and you
said like somebody was in your house,
how do you manage that? Like in
your personal life? Like, I dunno,
like we shared everything like,
oh,
right here with Mila and
we're having a great time.
And then like a lot of people can't. I
don't know like how to manage though. No,
probably both. I don't
have social media. Oh cool.
Neither does Kate.
So that is how we manage social media.
Yeah.
By not having a Google.
So that's that. But to your point, um,
the biggest problem that I have with
people, um, that's a horrible statement.
That's not what I meant to say.
Like in,
in like as far as people taking photos
and posting them is when I'm with my kids,
I do ask them to post it after I
leave only for security reasons.
Why am I just don't post that you're here
with me if my child in the background,
I just don't want that posted like an hour
later to your point. But I don't have,
we don't have social media,
but we've heard of this Google when
we hear it's great and you guys have a
Google phone, we hear that's
lovely. And uh, you know,
other great Google things.
Yay. Eric Schmidt, right
Larry Page. Guys I know words.
I thank you.
I use the search engine
surrogates all the time.
Google things. It's like a
verb. We Google then all day.
Um, this nice little girl.
The girl. Describe the,
that the woman standing back there.
I had a question.
Favorite musical guests who spit on
SNL since you've been on the cast?
Good question. My goodness. You know what?
You know what there was this week when,
I don't know if you've heard of Adele.
She came and she was that
week that she also did,
she filmed her live concert at Radio
City Music Hall and we all got to go.
And that was um,
it's the biggest venue in the world.
Maybe that's not correct,
but it sure looks like the base, you know
that I performed a radio city musical.
What did you do?
Finish your story and then I'll tell you
anyway, she did, she
sang her glorious voice,
filled the valid hallowed
halls and it was transcendent.
What was your story?
Well,
cause you were talking about Radio City
Music Hall and at one point Fema Guy,
we did live readings all around.
That's why, why parts and yet,
and um,
and so we performed all at different
theaters and we sold out radio city music
hall a couple of nights and I was like,
you know what,
if I'm going to stand on
the stage and perform,
I want to put on some tap shoes and then
say I can perform at radio city music
hall. So I put it on tap shoes and tap my
way down the stage once. And when look,
I performed at Radio City Music Hall and
that was like my big story that I can
tell people now.
Do you?
I want it to say,
but I performed at Radio City Music Hall,
so you can tell him I'm a rock
star in a real spirit, but not,
well a failed rockstar
who can't sing or town,
but performing radio city music hall.
That's all the time we have you guys.
Thank you so much for joining us.
[inaudible] on August
3rd it's really funny.
Thank you everyone for being here.